hi there steve kaufman
today i want to talk briefly about
grammar and about my recent trip to
peace river
um
i was recently up in northern alberta in
the peace river country which is
spectacular country
there are
great fields of wheat and canola which
is rapeseed
forest there's oil
not so many people but very friendly
people
and a rougher sort of different
lifestyle to what we have here in
vancouver
i fly to edmonton and then from edmonton
transfer you know take another flight to
grand prairie and then drive two and a
half hours north
um
the reason i mention it is because uh
while on my plane actually we were
flying from grand prairie to uh edmonton
there was a passenger who spoke only
french
and he was asking his neighbor who was a
lady who was this
basically an english speaker
what would it was a young fellow and
probably not a very experienced traveler
and he was trying to find out what
happens to his luggage
and so this lady was trying to explain
in her high school french she did quite
well compared to the level of most
uh english-speaking canadians
but what struck me was that here was
this woman who had quite a few words
but all her verbs were in the infinitive
you know
vu
whatever
and i have noticed that often
that
graduates of the canadian
uh you know english school system who
learned french
all they really remember is the words
the despite the emphasis on grammar and
in particular in french obviously in all
latin languages
the tenses are a problem because
depending on you know
uh person and number and
and yeah you know i you we
go did go you know went everything
changes and in english we're not used to
that so there's a lot of emphasis i
remember from my school days and i know
it hasn't changed a lot of emphasis on
the tenses and yet overwhelmingly people
graduate and they speak in the
infinitive
because
teaching people about grammar doesn't
enable them to produce it correctly
rather
lots of exposure does and that's why in
now granted english may be easier
insofar as tenses are concerned maybe
not
but uh swedish kids who watch a lot of
english language television speak much
better english
than
english speaking kids in canada who go
through french in school so being taught
grammar doesn't mean that you can
produce it correctly rather and i keep
on harping on this lots of exposure lots
of listening lots of reading eventually
speaking making mistakes picking up on
your mistakes listening some more
gradually that's going to ingrain these
habits because for a speaker of a
language which is not inflected very
much like english it's a difficult habit
to get into that even you you may know
theoretically you know je vette va ilvar
when you go to speak the brain doesn't
want to do it because it's not used to
doing it until you have had enough
exposure so i just wanted to make that
point and i'm going to it's going to be
a short one today and i'm going to end
up with a few
shots from my iphone
uh first you'll see some of the fields i
think these are canola fields a bumper
crop up there in the peace river and
then i went of course to visit our
sawmill up there and the mill manager
real and his wife kim
uh took us on the peace river and it's
fairly far north i mean there's not very
many people
and rather than uh normally we stay at
riya's place in the town of manning
which is about a thousand people
in the town
and lots of farms in the area the next
town is probably 100 you know
significant town is 100 kilometers away
um so anyway we went on the river up the
river a ways
to a little kind of cabin he has no
running water no electricity and we sat
there and we cooked up some steaks drank
some wine the wine is we had we got
extra protein from the flies that were
in our wine uh
and and and just again you know it was
like 30 degrees
celsius whatever that is in fahrenheit
during the day sunny and very warm
in the morning at around seven in the
morning as we were on the river heading
back to manning it was six degrees
celsius that's how big the difference is
so i will end up then with these videos
and thank you for listening bye for now
here we are as we're about to get on the
boat here
uh on the uh
mighty peace river
uh
delivered by that truck
and uh
about to get on
and i will uh shut this down before i
fall getting into the boat you can send
me yeah yeah so here we are we're
approaching this is an abandoned indian
lodge
this is where during the early wars
between the different tribes
this was the home of the chief
historical historical site
which and we're not allowed to trespass
here but the ours must do it regularly
and then we hope the rcmp doesn't find
us
we're gonna hit shore here all right
i thought you were gonna shave the like
little and then they don't have time
it's gonna get dark rub those sticks
together and all around last week
why don't you just scorch the meat
directly
anyway boy this is beautiful here
that is good
you know you would have liked romania